hey guys i'm off the grid for august but
joe scarborough is still pulling [ __ ]
out of his ass
work around because this thing
that this gop represents under its
current leadership
is now increasingly more dangerous than
it's ever been
and that is that is profoundly important
to understand right now
you know why
because they're fascists like people
that are making the threats
the people that helped donald trump on
january 6th
the people that were talking about
coming to
dc that it was going to be crazy that it
was going to what were going to be wild
they were going to charge the cap
they're fascists and so they're making
fascist threats and we need to do what
the united states has always done uh we
need to confront fascism and defeat it
so everybody that's freaking out over
fascists being fascists well guess what
that's what fascists do that's why we
have law enforcement
to actually bring fascists to justice so
please don't run around with your hair
on fire and say oh my god
we can't actually enforce the laws of
our land
we can't actually protect classified
documents because fascists may get upset
on a tv show that's what they do
you